passer au témoin du jour on va revenir
sur cette histoire incroyable autour de
l'acteur français Alain Delon alors
Alain Delon c'est un des plus grands
acteurs français de tous les temps hein
il a joué dans la piscine de swimming
pool notamment euh
pour swimming pool pour rappelle ces
trois enfants Anthony Anouka et Alain
Fabien porté plainte contre sa dame de
de compagnie Homi Rolin qui se présente
comme sa compagne pour ils ont porté
plainte pour harcèlement moral et
détournement de fond on va revenir sur
les déclarations d'Antony et plus
récemment celle d'anouka au micro de
cette à 8 hier soir vous allez voir
c'est assez incroyable pour nous en
parler on va recevoir Jean-Pierre
lesclus c'est un ami d'blelinon depuis
plus de 20 ans et il y aura également
myiam
Palomba on les accueille tout de suite
juste après cette première prise de
parole d'Anouchka donc une des filles
d'Alain Delon qui nous raconte sa
rencontre avec iromi donc qui était au
départ la dame de compagnie d'anindon
regardez moi je l'ai rencontré il y a 20
ans sur le tournage du film Le Lion que
j'ai tourné avec mon père en fait elle
était assistante réalisatrice sur le
plateau après c'est une femme que bah
qui s'occupait de notre maison en fait
de de la résidence secondaire de notre
père donc je la voyais comme ça mais il
m'a jamais vraiment présenté cette femme
officiellement comme étant sa compagne
dans ce cas-là j'en ai rencontré plein
des compagnes je peux vous dire que même
pour son AVC il y a 4 ans j'en ai j'en
ai vu desfil et des compagnes à
l'hôpitaloup alors Miriam Palomba merci
d'être là et je voudrais remercier
Jean-Pierre lesclus projectionniste et
ami d'Alain
Delon avant tout est-ce que euh vous
vous avant qu' remis hre dans la vie
d'un lon vous é changz régulièrement
avec lui vous étiez très potte avec lui
oui très bien très bien ou très bien
tout allait très bien et après elle est
arrivée et tout allait très mal a ce qui
s'est passé je ne sais pas j'étais pas
au courant je suis pas au courant mais
je sais qu'à chaque fois que je voulais
voir Alain Delon dans sa propriété ça
m'était refusé c'est ça ouais alors que
terminé terminé alors qu'avant vous
étiez euh souvensble Avon je travaillais
pendant 22 ans avec lui ouais ah ouais
on tout se passait très bien très très
bien lendemain terminé du jour le
lendemain c'est fini plus de Jean-Pierre
plus de Jean-Pierre un cononnu au
bataillon terminé c'est fou ça re vous
avez essayé de de l'avir Alain de lui
dire qu'est-ce qui se passe impossible
impossible m au téléphone pas du tout au
téléphone puisque c'est elle qui l'avait
le téléphone non ah c'est un truc de fou
vous avez essayé de lui rendre visite
d'y aller directement de dire voilà je
veux parler à alin possible
impossible répondait àin Deon n'est pas
là non ah ouais donc s'il est pas là moi
je savais très bien pertinemment qu'il
était là vous la connaissiez avant non
pas du tout pas du tout du jour au
lendemain vous avez la vu arriver dans
la maison bah disons que on s'est
rencontré avec Alain Delon et puis sa sa
compagne
enfin si on peut dire une compagne au
cinéma le Vox à châur renard d'accord
pour présenter le film de Fabien Alain
Fabien c'est ça et donc ce jour-là Alain
Deon était là il y avait ironie qui
était là aussi j'ai voulu faire des
photos avec lui comme il s'est présenté
derrière là ouais ça m'a été refusé par
elle et Alain Delon a dit si on va la
faire la photo ah ouais voilà donc voyez
ah oua photo on a fait cette photo il a
plus personne comment il y a plus
personne
ouis juste avant la séance de ciné juste
avant oui
d'accord et puis et puis il y avait le
numéro de téléphone le fameux numéro de
téléphone que que Alain Delon m'a
demandé et qu'elle a voulu garder dans
sa poche d'accord iromie
iromie iromie vous par parz ou pas du
tout vous elle vous calculez pas parce
que on voit que c'est sa compagne là oui
mais moi avec elle aucun aucun
commentaire rien rien à dire myiam cette
histoire est folle on va voir ce qu'a
dit anoukaier elle a une très bonne
relation avec son père ce qui selon elle
rendrait complètement jalouse iromi elle
voudrait en fait écarter tous ceux qui
que Alain aimait bien c'est ça tous ceux
qui gênaient il étent écartés et vous
vous gênnez et moi je gênais parce que
Alain vous aimez bien voilà P vous avez
envie de le revoir oui bien sûr il vous
manque un peu ben passer 22 ans avec lui
ah ouais c'est ça c'est pas c'est pas
rien pas un an c'est pas 2 ans c'est pas
10 ans non plus et du jour au lendemain
terminé oui terminus tout le monde
descend bon regarde regarde des Nouche
était jalouse de tout et de tout le
monde je veux dire des gens qui venaient
le voir de ses amis qui lui envoyai des
messages c'est pour ça qu'après le
pauvre à un moment donné il avait plus
de message en fait elle s'amusait à
effacer les messages avant qu'il les
lise et on a commencé à se prendre la
tête elle et moi au téléphone et et
chose qu'elle n'avait jamais fait avant
en fait elle m'a interdit de venir voir
mon père et m'a interdit de enfin de le
voir en fait elle m'a dit tu reviens
plus jamais dans cette maison ici c'est
ma maison tu reviens plus là je vous
avoue que je me suis dit c'est bon faut
faire quelque chose parce que ça peut
pas continuer comme ça ouais ça fait Joh
ah ouais mais c'est pas johnny c'est
allant euh Myriam Palomba pourquoi vous
êtes venu je sais pas bon m'appère a une
heure j'ai dit ok je viens c'est sympa
ici je passe un bon temp qu'est-ce que
disnous ce que tu veux nous dire parce
que cour Mo mais si si si j'ai j'ai des
questions normalement que vous êtes
censé me poser
ah bonjour Miriam
bonjour selon Anthony le fils d'Alain il
est impossible chronologiquement parlant
qu'omis soit avec Alain depuis 30 ans
vous confirmez oui je confirme merci il
a déjà été manipulé par d'autres
personnes dans sa vie non mais je confi
je vais expliquer pourquoi quand même
y oui non voulez pas mais si chérie
vas-y non c'est impossible parce que en
fait elle parle de d'une relation de 33
ans ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que à que
Anouchka a 33 ans que alin Fabien son
frère a 27 ans et que à l'époque où elle
était où elle dit avoir commencé une
histoire avec Alain Delon elle était
Alain Delon était avec leur maman
Rosalie van briman qui est un beau un
superbe mannequin de l'époque et que du
coup les dates ne correspondent pas du
tout à ce qu'elle dit c'est ça euh je
vais une autre question à vous poserou
euh quelle était la nature de leur
relation ils étaient bien ensemble avec
bah en fait c'est là je les vois ils ont
pas l'air ils ont pas l'air mais après
qu' au cinéma là ah bah oui là
oui alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
mais bon 10 et 10 au deux yeux
elle a été elle est très proche de lui
mais c'est surtout depuis qu'il a eu son
AVC Alain Delon c'est un homme affaibli
depuis qu'il a eu son AVC en 2019 et ce
que disent ses enfants c'est qu'en fait
elle a profité de de cette faiblesse
pour se rapprocher de lui mais qu'à
aucun moment jusqu'à 2019 iromi était
considéré comme sa compagne et les
enfants de d'Alain Deon disent que leur
père ne leur a jamais dit que c'était sa
compagne même si elle dit que depuis
2001 elle partageait le lit de Alain
Delon tout le temps oui le le point de
faiblesse de la famille Delon c'est que
à un moment Alain Delon l'a présenté
comme sa compagne il l'a dit dans une
interview donc du coup il vous il l'a
présenté comme sa compagne oui j'ai su
ça oui donc du coup elle elle s'appuie
là-dessus bien sûr euh en disant voilà
moi je je suis la compagne depuis
longtemps et Alain Delon a dit après
j'ai dit ça pour être débarrassé
d'elle pour être tranquille Alain il dit
que c'est pas sa compagne non maintenant
il dit ça il dit j'ai dit que c'était ma
compagne pour être tranquille elle me
saoulait voilà ce qu'il dit maintenant
appuyé par les enfants oui oui oui Non
Non mais en fait il a donné deux
interviews effectivement à TV5 Monde et
à Paris Match où il parle de sa compagne
japonaise mais comme comme ses enfants
l'expliquent c'est que elle le saoulait
tellement elle lui hurlait dessus en lui
disant que qu'elle voulait absolument
qu'il se marie et Cera elle a dit elle a
dit dans une interview homie qu'elle il
y avait un mariage programmé euh avec
Alain oui c'est ce qu'elle dit mais même
Anouchka dans l'interview qu'elle a
donné elle explique qu'un jour elle a
appelé Alain et que elle l'a entendu
hurler derrière derrière lui il faut
absolument qu'on se marie j'en ai marre
ça peut plus durer elle elle elle était
quasi hystérique selon les propos de
d'anouia et quand après Anouka l'a
appelé pour lui dire mais qu'est-ce qui
se passe pourquoi tu hurles comme ça
auprès de de mon mon père sur mon père
elle a elle a nié évidemment elle ais
une voix une voix toute douce et et elle
a nié tous ses propos alors Anouka
raconte même qu'elle aurait remplacé
toutes les photos de famille de la
maison avec des photos d'Alain et elle
je sais pas si vous êtes retourné depuis
plus de photos de famille il y a que
Alain et elle là actuellement vous aviez
des photos avec lui vous à part cell non
sin les les enfants ont été pr en photo
avec lui oui ça parce que sinon elle
enlève toutes les photos dès qu'il y a
une photoelun
d're j'avais l'impression moi que
c'était un décor à chaque fois que
j'allais le voir il y avait des photos
d'elle et de lui partout et avant il y
avait d'autres photos bah il y avait des
photos de ma mère de de de d'Alain
Fabien de moi d'Anthony de Nathalie de
Mireille de Romy il y avait même une
photo de mon mari de moi et de mon fils
et c'est la femme de ménage qui qui
m'appelle un jour qui me dit Oh madame
Delon je suis choquée je fais le ménage
et je retrouve la photo de vous de votre
mari et de votre fils dans un tiroir je
dis en fait àain Delon n'existe plus
Alain le papa n'existe plus Alain le
mari n'existe plus c'est grave de faire
ça
il y a plus de photo plus une photo il
plus de photoéditation mais je te le dis
Jean-Pierre Jean-Pierre toi quand tu
Allis à la maison il disait il y a plus
d' pas l'in Deon alors qu'in il était là
oui bien sûr la dernière fois que je
suis retourné il y a à peu près un mois
ouais là j'ai j'ai sonné et donc il y un
monsieur qui est venu au portail un
monsieur qui est venu j'avais un dossier
à lui remettre je lui ai remis dit était
pas là homis non noni était pas là et
puis j'ai donné et puis il a dit j'ai je
vous demanderai de transmettre ça à
Monsieur Delon dit il y a pas de
problème donc Delon était bien là ah oui
donc il était là voilà vous avez pas
demandé à le voir mais avec elle c'est
mais avec lui vous avez pas pu ven dire
au gars c'est Jean-Pierre il quoi non
non il voulait voir personne en plus le
gars m'avait dit à cette heure-ci il
dort encore du matin quelle heure 10h du
matin vous avez pas été chez Kelly
plutôt non
mais 10h du matin ouais donc il dort pas
jusqu'à 10h du matin non m non et sil
voulait vraiment plus vous voir vous AZ
pensé
ça
question plaisanta précise après malgré
tout il est il a eu un AVC donc
j'imagine qu'il est très faible il a
peut-être même des troubles cognitifs il
est très diminué moi je trouve c'est
toujours un peu bizarre et je mise pas
dans leur vie parce que je la connais
pas que des enfants disent en gros oui
mais elle a elle a fait le vide et tout
ça enfin on est enfant on peut aussi
s'occuper de de notre
elle était bien pratique quand Mme cette
femme pour s'occuper au
quoen donc je trouve que d'un côté elle
était pratique et maintenant on lu
trouve tout les T ouis Auel de ça quand
tu entends tous les discours de tout le
monde tu as l'impression qu'il est
séquestré et quem faut le
sauver plus de photos
phot même la photo de avecib Bouchard
elle enlevé tout enevé plus photo tu vas
là-bas tu vois plus une photo Jeanpierre
en tout cas merci d'être venu jeanierre
et si tu veux tu peux venir chez moi je
ser toujours he de teevoir
non mais je teblé une photo et je me
lève tôt vous me donnerez vot votre
adresse et puis avec grand plaisir
Jean-Pierre tu sais quoi tu viens me
voirve